imagine if we detonated a nuclear bomb
in space actually you don't have to
you can see for yourself that was
starfish prime
the highest altitude nuclear test in
history
in 1962 the u.s government launched a
1.4
megaton bomb from johnston island and
detonated it
400 kilometers above the pacific about
as
high as where the international space
station orbits today
the detonation generated a giant
fireball
and created a burst of energy called an
electromagnetic
pulse or emp that expanded for over
1 000 kilometers emps can cause a power
surge
damaging electronic equipment in the
process and this one
was no different across hawaii street
lights went dark
telephones went down and navigation and
radar systems
went out not to mention the six or so
satellites that failed
and all this came from a 1.4 megaton
bomb
zarbamba which was the largest nuclear
bomb that was ever detonated
was 50 megatons so what would happen
if we detonated that above the united
states
for starters there's no atmosphere in
space
so there would be no mushroom-shaped
cloud and
no subsequent blast wave or mass
destruction
instead you'd get a blinding fireball
four times the size of starfish primes
and if you look directly at it within
the first 10 seconds
you could permanently damage your eyes
satellites wouldn't be safe either
radiation from the explosion would fry
the circuits of hundreds of instruments
in low earth orbit
including communication satellites
military spy satellites
and even science telescopes like the
hubble plus
astronauts on board the international
space station might be at risk of
radiation poisoning
on the ground however you'd probably be
fine
the detonation point will be far enough
away that the high energy radiation
wouldn't reach you but don't get too
comfortable
remember starfish prime's emp this time
the emp would cover one third of the
entire united states
bringing down regional power grids and
electronics
like a lightning strike millions of
americans will be out of power for hours
or even days but it's not all doom and
gloom
the radiation would also interact with
oxygen and nitrogen in the atmosphere
and create a spectacular aurora near the
detonation site
that would last for days now let's be
clear
this will probably never happen super
thermonuclear
devices like zarbamba no longer exist
and even if they did
the tsar bomba weighed around 27 000
kilograms there are only a couple of
operational rockets in the world that
can manage to lift
something that heavy into space in the
first place
so we're probably safe from that anyway
this video was made in large part thanks
to the calculations from physicists at
los alamos national lab